I've never been nervous for a BuzzFeed
read before I think this is gonna suck
my name is Rodney my mom Janet my mama
Darlene Mary Helen Kathy my mother made
my friends didn't hit on my mom at least
I knew of oh my gosh today we have Kathy
don't even say your name she ever go
back at the goods if they had selfies
back in the day she didn't be just all
Kathy on the bed Kathy on her bed Kathy
on the bed just shimmy like let me get
this shirt off yeah she would fight like
you know a bleep I want to go down on a
knee right now I'd be a great stepdad to
Zach yeah great I haven't talked about
my mom in this context before about her
being sexy so kind of weirded out Janet
[Music]
your mom is high dude I'm a gay man not
yours she's just like a sexy woman I
don't know describe yeah like with all
do I didn't think we were gonna say the
word sexy today she gets more sexy as
she gets yeah as time goes on somehow
she's like Jennifer Lopez like if this
for the boy next door
right I would be the boy next door Wow
creeping on my friends never hit on my
mom it's my house in the funhouse but
not because they wanted to have sex with
my mom
I don't know I don't know now oh man oh
man a little romp ik look that off like
in time like this could have been no
this was Thursday this was Friday just
pure but is Shukur yes yes are you sure
she had sex twice once for me dude my
sister I think she could pull any dude
at the bar I believe it looking at me
hi I think it's like the Magic Castle or
something
whose age right Darlene is sexy for me
to even think about what my peers would
like about my mom is strange we have
Justin's mom Mei Mei sorts going on yeah
yo your mom's have nice legs in this
photo she looks elegant like success
elegant and delicate I try to kiss your
mom on the first date I don't know if
it'll work
she's got the lips she's got the legs
she's a great mouth yeah your mom is
aging very black and Asian don't crack
did your mom like Disney World
I'll make sure for Ben oh really because
I've got a date in mind well that is a
beautiful woman but I don't think my
friends saw her as someone to Parvati
Mary Helen she's by a nun
sounds like a nun she's clearly not this
lady is like a teacher that you maybe
have a crush on or something your mom
was a model oh yeah I think she's
undercover wild this all white like
jacket type thing nice it screams power
which is very attractive Wow she has
that glare that just says yeah do you
real quick no offense is Zach Zach's mom
but she can get it sorry I was awful I
don't want to ever hear Rodney say
anything about my mother ever again I
was actually surprised that they didn't
go in a lot a lot harder in a
it's flattering you know it's like Oh
your mom this is where you get it here
we go hey the most surprisingly was that
everybody's mom was attractive thank God
hey mom hi Janet hi Janet I'll get your
number from Randy and I'd like to give
you a call when he loves these guys want
to like touch you